and the in the spirit for best feature
goes to
the lost daughter
[Applause]
this is the third win for maggie
gyllenhaal and the lost daughter tonight
maggie shares this win with fellow
producers charles dorfman ozanat
handelson karen and talia kleinhandler
filming of the lost daughter took place
on the island of spetsis in greece
[Applause]
[Music]
what an incredible time to the room
thank you all so much
making this movie was such a wonderful
experience but more than anything
we really want to thank all
of the parents especially the mothers
that came to us after seeing this movie
and felt that they were seeing
that their experiences are on screen
that it's okay to not always be perfect
with everything thank you all so much
but especially
to our mothers who are brave and
talented and loving and nurturing and we
wouldn't be here without them so thank
you to our mothers
thank you to our beautiful friend maggie
gyllenhaal
maggie you are a brilliant director a
brilliant writer we were in awe of you
every single day being on this journey
with you has been one of the greatest
privileges of our lives
thank you
to our amazing cast to olivia coleman
jesse buckley dakota johnson doug mar
domincic peter sarsgaard ed harris
paul mezcal and all these wonderful
actors
thank you to our beautiful crew to helen
luvar
to fonzie
[Applause]
tinbal to dicken to everyone who made
this movie possible thank you to
endeavor and wme for supporting us
believing in us going along with all our
crazy ideas we love you
deb neguin kelly
thank you to
netflix you're such a wonderful home for
filmmakers thank you for
getting our movie out into the world to
more people than we could have possibly
imagined would see this movie thank you
so much
and thank you to who did i forget
to our
to our beautiful children who accept our
flawed motherhood every day
to our husbands who support us and thank
you so much to elena ferrante for
putting such profound truth into the
world and trusting us with that truth
thank you so much
[Music]
i forgot someone wait maggie no
no i just wanted to thank um
uh my mom
and my dad
and amanda silverman
[Applause]
women in film
thank you thank you
[Applause]